why were you in China I went to my son
is studying a mandarin in high school so
he wanted to go to China and I couldn't
back out of it he said you know Jackie
Chan daddy we got to go so I went over
that Jackie took care of us we went to a
different restaurant every night but it
was same thing what's he like in China
with Jackie Chan is it just ridiculous
he's the man Jackie owned everything
he's like you like Hotel he said you
like Hotel I said yeah it's my hotel
that's my hotel no so I got to do more
movies
and then he was like why are you over
here I said I came to see you what do
you think I'm over here for you the only
person I know in China
it like walks around with like 15 people
and then I'm like in the back of the 15
people Jackie wait up hold up foreign